[موسيقى]
جماهير المغرب تخطف الاضواء في المونديال
ومشجع الياباني يشكر مديره في العمل ومدرب
الاسباني يشيد بالمنتخب السعودي هذه
الاخبار وغيرها تتابعونها على العربيه
رياضه اهلا بكم
خطفت الجماهير المغربيه الاضواء في استاد
البيت خلال موقعه منتخب بلادها ضد كرواتيا
واستغل مشجع المغرب رؤوسهم
للمنتخب في مشواره
بعض الجماهير المغربيه
واجهه مشجع ياباني رساله شكر من المدرجات
القطريه
حرس مواجهه لمدير في العمل بعد ان منحه
اجازه لمده اسبوعين من اجل متابعه منتخب
بلاده في كاس العالم ومن حسن حظيفه
اليابان على المانيا بهدفين مقابل هدف
الى جانب النتيجه الايجابيه الياباني
يضربون مثلا في النظافه والاحترام مره
اخرى فبعد الفيديو الذي انتشر لهم في حفل
الافتتاح وهم ينظفون ملعب مباراه قطر
وظهروا اليوم مره اخرى
[موسيقى]
في المؤتمر الصحفي الذي يسبق لقاء منتخب
السنبا بسربيا غدا عن طريقه لاعبي منتخب
بلاده في الاحتفال يوسف ان تحترم ثقافتنا
والرقص جزء منها في نفس القدر الذي نحترم
به ثقافتكم
ايش هذا مدرب منتخب اسبانيا لويس انريكي
بلاعبي ومدرب المنتخب السعودي بعد فوز
الاخضر امس على المنتخب الارجنتيني بهدفين
مقابل هدف واضاف امريكي لا ننسى صوت
المنتخب السعودي سابقا على اليابان
الموجوده في المجموعه
فازت اليوم على كوستاريكا بالسبعه اهداف
مقابل لا شيء
[موسيقى]